our sit-down with former cause we start
keshia knight pulliam is making
headlines everywhere the actress who
played adorable Rudy Huxtable had a
world turned upside down earlier this
week when her husband filed for divorce
yeah he filed for divorce just days
after she announced she was pregnant and
on top of that he is now allegedly
requested a paternity test to prove that
the child really is his tonight more of
Michelle Turner's exclusive interview
there have been reports that said you
all weren't getting along from pretty
much the beginning there were lots of
arguments yeah
that's right you didn't birthday was in
May you didn't spend his birthday
together all of those things are they
true it's funny how people try to spin
things and I'm not gonna allow someone
to rewrite the truth there's feelings
there's a baby this is a baby in the
middle of this and regardless if we
don't want to be married that's fine cuz
we agree on that we neither one of us
want to be now you don't want to be in
this I have joining designer the same
day is our interview Keisha filed her
own divorce papers in response and it
appears these two didn't have a prenup
Keisha who's reportedly worth twelve
million dollars says she wants all the
money she earned before the marriage
that includes The Cosby Show and get
this in ed Hartwell stocks he stated
there's no children
Kisha points out there are no minor
children but one is expected have you
seen ed Hartwell or spoken to him after
the divorce filing on Monday after he
told you Monday mm-hmm there's nothing
to say I'm not about dragging people
through the mud in the media because
even with the paternity test one day he
will have to answer to her and explained
to her I don't like this like what I'll
be flying you want me to do no one could
have predicted this future for the
former Cosby kid but Kisha is staying
positive and focusing on her family that
includes her nine year old stepson EJ
that's the hardest part
I really really loved him he was so
excited every night he would hug me I
love you
pshhh pshhh that's the name for me and
they can't say to the baby and I love
you
and I hate that he doesn't have that
experiencing he deserves to be a big
thing